happy 400th anniversary castle rockers
apologies on getting this video out a
bit later than usual and for me blazing
through this episode my schedule has
been completely bonkers this week and
wow this episode has completely thrown
the show on its head so let's not waste
any time and get right into it and at
the end I'll go over my thoughts on the
hooded figure which if you've seen
season one is a huge twist we are in New
Jerusalem in the year 1619 a French
colony which has been hit with hard
times Augustine the town priest who in
present day has taken over the body of
ice Merrill conducts a service for a
young girl who has died he's interrupted
by a MIDI a MIDI coming from the French
word for friendship and friendship I
also want to quickly mention that we see
her drawing with charcoal something that
is mimicked throughout the episode and
one of de Lacey from season one's
favorite ways to draw you might also
remember a MIDI from season 1 when Henry
Deaver ventures into the thinny
tinnie I don't know how to pronounce it
if you want to know more about that I
suggest you watch my season 1 episode 9
breakdown which I'll link below
she says the land is cursed something
her father Marius does not believe her
disobedience combined with fascination
of the natives and her affair with
father Augustine caused her and
Augustine to be banished which in 1619
was basically a death sentence when all
seems lost she's approached by a hooded
figure on the very cliff where Henry
Deaver killed his father in season 1 and
will definitely be coming back to that
machan present day at the Marston home
the settlers have begun work on a mural
depicting the events of a manie's rise
to prominence we'll see several these
pictures throughout the episode but
there's one in particular that is quite
foreboding a floating angel atop a
burning city now this could either be a
nod to the kid and the fires that
gripped Castle Rock last season or
something that has yet to happen Annie
is detained at the lodge and questioned
where she states that the death of Rita
was in self-defense she wants to make
sure her sister joy doesn't go down for
what happened we get this shot of pop
holding some bullets over this ledger we
know pop loans money and it's
interesting to see the Church of the
Incarnation here maybe they needed some
for the Marston home in that swell new
statue pop goes back to Shawshank and
it's just amazing to see Tim Robbins
return back to the prison he escaped
from you'll notice some familiar set
pieces here like this hallway and the
visitation room which were seen in
season one pop is here to see his
brother-in-law John who killed his
sister Brenda leaving him with two kids
ace and Chris to take care of with pop
having a few weeks to live he's come to
forgive John but learns that ace who
hadn't seen John in over two decades
visited him it's only when he
interrogate shimmy one of the prison
guards that he finds out ace wanted into
Dale Lacey's cage where he kept the kid
in in season one even stranger is that
the cage was locked and the only thing
left inside were some prison issued
clothes the last we saw of the kid was
the end of season one where Henry Deaver
kept him locked up so unless this is
some alternate Castlerock universe
something happened between then and now
the locked cage suggests he made his way
out perhaps through a thinny back in
1619 am near Ives back in New Jerusalem
with food she tells them she was visited
by an angel well seen as a blessing her
father says it's witchcraft Augustin
goes on to call her a prophet but my
guess is that her prophecies all come
from the kid who has come from the
future ace is with his followers telling
them almost all 38 of them have their
vessels they've decided to make their
first move in front of the church what
they consider a temple to a false God
the only problem is that their vessel
annie has been taken into police custody
he assigns Patrice to take care of it
but later finds out Patrice was
unsuccessful and even questions ASE's
decision to have Annie as the vessel
they have only a few days left and Annie
is on all sorts of meds that we know can
affect the transformation aka the
weaving process Patrice is questioning
later finds him burned upside down when
Abdi discovers the burning crosses also
interesting to note that the crosses are
upside down which usually indicates the
opposite of God back in 1619 the
supposed angel of which they now have a
carving of an warship has asked of them
something terrible to sacrifice
themselves to be reborn 400 years later
in order to
conquer the new world this process
involves them constructing coffins
eating beetles and slitting their
throats
hence the bloody knife we saw a MIDI
hold in season one
these scarab beetles symbolize
immortality and resurrection and were
heavily used in Egyptians in funerary
art the last to to die our Amity and
Augustine she tells him he'll be the
first to resurrect and she the last and
tasks him with finding the angel which
is why he was likely searching at
Shawshank
but there's another angel we know of the
ravening angel is that the kid annie joy
will have to keep these possibilities
open our final scene finds a son veiling
the statue of the kid which seemingly
hypnotizes everyone who beholds it
everyone except for pop who was pushed
aside when it was unveiled ace has
something big planned but for it to
fully take effect he'll still need to
resurrect a MIDI we also don't know to
what degree this hypnotized ation will
take hold is it temporary or are all the
townspeople now under his control but
the biggest shocker of the episode is
the revelation that the kid from season
one is this supposed angel now season
one left it very ambiguous as to the
motives of the kid is he good or is he
bad if it was indeed the kid who told a
MIDI to burn her father on an
upside-down cross kill all of her people
and conquer the world when she's
resurrected then it can probably be safe
to say he is evil now the current theory
going around is that the kid is the
crimson king an immortal being in the
Stephen King universe who is said to be
the same species as it which would be
ironic since skarsgård plays it in the
films the crimson king is also known to
control minions such as vampires as well
as humans in the book Salem's Lot it's
vampires who take over the Marston home
and it's looking a lot like the kid has
control over the people in the Marston
home through Amity the kid never aging
also matches with the Crimson Kings
immortality and because he is
supernatural it could explain him being
able to escape Lacy's prison the other
connection this episode didn't focus on
are the letters Nadia found in pops
drawer the ones between de Lacy and
Allan penguin
which likely discuss the kid why would
pop have these letters and to what
extent does he know about the kid in the
cage it's possible pop had these letters
as blackmail I would imagine a prison
warden and former sheriff working
together to hold a prisoner in captivity
would be quite the story but with both
of these characters now dead why does he
still have them we're gonna have to stay
tuned until next week for more answers
but this episode was a great way to ramp
up the story going into the final three
episodes I hope you'll give this video a
like and leave a comment as I have more
Castle Rock videos coming out you can
also follow me on Twitter at pings story
whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
[Music]